in the town of hazaki 5000 men are being
held amongst them British fighter Ishaq
Mustafa who traveled to Syria in 2013 he
spoke two skies Middle East
correspondent Mark Stone who has this
special report and the warning it
contains some graphic images of the many
things to hit you when you walk into
this place
the silence is one
it's mid-afternoon but with a power cut
the places in darkness beyond these
gates behind the walls in cells left and
right are thousands of Isis prisoners
here they wait while their countries
wonder what to do with them they are
from all over the world captured here in
Syria when the Caliphate they created
fell hello
you're British no I'm German you're
German
you speak English how long have you been
here since 8 months what do you think
now about the Islamic state and I had
there were some people made call me to
you
and told me that you can Revere Islamic
and the end
[Music]
that wasn't
it wasn't what what was expected
you understand why people are not
sympathetic I understand sir I said I
told you well sanhui everybody here they
did a mistake and everybody here they
feel guilty they know what they did what
do you think of - what do you think of
Isis everybody here they know the truth
of Isis they know there are there big
Liars there making use of Islam there
making use of the our our religion
we're taken to the prison clinic this is
where the war wounded are held
disfigured
still bandaged eight months on make a
point about my face being showed can you
just blur it out if you can among them
Isaac Mustafa we from Layton East London
tell me what how long you've been in
Syria I relisted I came here in the late
2013-2014 so you you admit you joined
the Islamic state you Joey you joined -
I was within the Islamic state living
under the Islamic state yeah your own
choice yeah what do you think of - of
the Islamic state now
well now it's over it's done it's over
and done with and we're here you know
with the fractured skull one thing to go
out to another you know go back to what
we've done before we've been here for
the last nine months not knowing about
our families but do you believe in what
- stands for no no no done a lot of
mistakes and you know life isn't is a
curry lesson curve you know it's a
learning curve like we say they cut
people's heads off in Raqqa I'm doing
were you involved with that no not at
all you know did you see that happening
no no I was not involved in that and we
couldn't them all the crimes and
oppression that they they that they
actually did to the people here
do you wish any harm on the UK so the
bombings that we've seen in Manchester
you may not even know about it the
Manchester Arena bombing the London
Bridge attack do you know about these
okay these were carried out in the past
few years by followers of - photos of
the Islamic state and many people died
I have no involvement in that I I don't
know what believe him or not that's a
judgment no one is making instead
governments globally pretend they are
not here in a control room a single
Kurdish guard watches the screens each
is a cell each with dozens inside there
was an attempted break out a few weeks
ago it failed only just and from the man
in charge here a stark warning chat they
could be that it can occur as argue Gary
Kevin I think you will make a better
position there are no easy answers for
all this every option is bad to take
them back and attempt to prosecute or to
leave them are they all perpetrators or
are some victims duped by the cult
questions that for now no one is even
trying to answer
mark stone Sky News in hosaka Syria